before solo milks your nostalgia for the
original trilogy dry discover three
spin-offs that took everything you loved
about the old Star Wars movies and gave
you something let's just say different
the original Star Wars spin-offs kick
off an evening of crap with caravan of
courage the Ewok movie set before the
other Ewok movie but after the movie
that was 30% a walk
embark on an adventure with no one's
favorite unblinking murder bears as they
team up with another creature that's
better in small doses a kid together
they'll search for her missing parents
with her brother mace a Skywalker
knockoff with the hair of Luke and the
acting of Anakin
and of course Tinkerbell I think she
giggles
[Music]
Wow they were planning the seats at that
Disney buy out really early huh if
caravan of courage is the Hobbit then
get ready cuz battle of endor is Game of
Thrones
without question the darkest Star Wars
movie ever made where most of the Ewoks
are slaughtered in the opening scene the
four-year-olds whole family is massacred
she's kidnapped by a dragon and has to
spend the rest of her life getting
yelled at by Wilford Brimley I don't
want you here get out yeah that'll screw
up someone for life holy crap this is a
captain phasma prequel isn't it but
those are just warm-ups for the main
event watch the original Star Wars
trilogy lose its final shred of dignity
in the Star Wars Holiday Special a
project so bad George Lucas wanted to
destroyed forever
and that guy made attack of the clones
sit through this vaguely Star Wars
themed variety show where the only
variety is the level of drugs they were
on when they wrote it whether it's a
song from Mos Eisley cantina owner Bea
Arthur just friend
Santa homeward-bound friends a saw from
70 saw frog Titans Jefferson Starship
Ora saw from Princess Leia while
Harrison Ford regrets all of his life
choices
we all
now that's the face of a man who has a
really bad feeling about this
in between the talent sections enjoy a
tiny scrap of story
tying it all together we're chewing has
to get home to his beloved itchy mawa
and lumpy for life day which is like
Christmas but hairy and vaguely Wiccan
the Empire is on high alert
thanks to an overdub scene from a new
hope I want the rebels located been
identified but with no help from Lube or
Tsubaki
no help remilia send either to back or
Han Solo to the screen please and actual
help from one half of The Honeymooners
aren't corny I brought you that proton
pack I'm a Bob Chuy's family will spend
over an hour
horrific Lee groaning at each other
while you try to maintain your last
shred of sanity
[Music]
[Applause]
so melt your brain with three Star Wars
films so awful you'll never complain
about the prequels the last Jedi or solo
again because no matter what Disney
decides to throw at us next there's no
way it will be as bad as Chuy's dad
watching vr porn in the middle of the
living room did I did I just dream that
oh no no there it is that was real oh we
are excited
Hajis turn it off turn it off story
Muffit baby at least Warwick Davis got
paid you're a hairy wizard diabeetus
origins
best I ever had
magnificent Wilford Brimley dropping the
f-bomb in a TV movie for children
Jefferson's Star Destroyer Malibu Luke
Carrie Fisher giving zero shits lumpy
Space Prince and he did it all for the
wookie Star Wars the first sellouts you
know the weirdest thing about these
movies is the first appearance of Boba
Fett and it's awesome I take it you have
no love of the Empire
I don't follow me friend all they do is
eat death mother know you're aware of
her drapes
remember no can't I'm a potato head on a
potato head farm with my potato head
family be potato head strong